We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Take a listen to this one.
Hi, David.
I'm a recent member.
I recently canceled my recurring NPR donation.
You remember since your show was pretty virtuous.
I want to let you know I really love your
show for two reasons.
One is the rational, sober adherence to truth
and reality over partisanship when it's necessary.
I really appreciate hearing hard truths over
pleasing lies or optimistic magical thinking.
Number two, because of your lack of hyperbole
and B.S., I still share your videos.
I know the info is going to be solid and I
won't have to spend time defending the source.
I really enjoy what you're putting out, man.
I love the voicemail.
I love the financial support.
I love the ideological support and the sharing
on social media support.
That being said, we're not asking people to
cancel NPR to sign up for The David Pakman
Show.
I guess for some people it's one or the other.
NPR.
Very important people who primarily get news
from NPR are much more informed than people
who primarily get news from many other sources.
So we love NPR.
We love our supporters.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I have a crazy story from the weekend involving
the police.
OK, I'm not going to say more.
I will tell it.
On today's bonus script.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dicom.